[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors everything with you John and Hank
it's a comedy podcast where two brothers
answer your question give UDV this
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John
how are you I'm very very cold
it's unfathomably cold here in
indianapolis at the moment and even
though this podcast won't go up for a
few days it will still be cold when the
podcast goes up Hank I've been living
near the White River for many years now
this is the first time I've ever seen
the White River for not only freeze
completely over but in fact there are
deer tracks that go from one side of the
white river to the other indicating to
me that a deer very likely survived the
traversing of the White River indicating
to me that I could potentially survive
such a traversing and I could go visit
my neighbors across the river but I'm
not going to attempt that because it's
too cold to even go outside let alone
risk falling into a river huge I mean
you could just you could just travel
that way you could go get yourself a
dogsled and just just yeah shoot on down
the White River it's colder in Missoula
than it is in Indianapolis though I
guess that's probably no no no no no
huge surprised to see any no no no no no
it's like 17 today in Missoula according
to the Google I just googled it's 21 in
Indianapolis
no Sheridan do you think that right now
outside it is 21 degrees no way no it is
like - at the very most it is between
zero and two no windchill and also the
only the Annapolis Starr website is the
worst place I've ever been
hey don't make fun of the Indianapolis
Star website I've you know I've written
for them before it also apparently
according to Google it's snowing and
then I looked outside and indeed it is
snowing so that is a surprise because I
was told that it was not going to snow
today and I wish that I had not driven
my card that can't drive in the snow and
now I don't know what to do and I'm a
little bit upset
I don't know how to proceed hey it's
dark difficult times that's all I'm
telling you he'd like advice on how to
be cold because I've been a negative
twenty it happens every year here and
then there the windchill will tack on to
that another another couple of minus ten
or ten or fifteen and then then you're
real it's just not it's not a good not a
good way to be all right yeah tell me
how to be cold Hank okay right so step
one put on your gloves before you put on
your coat because there will be a better
seal between your gloves and your coat
that way because you can't get your
gloves to go over your coat you want
your coat to go over your gloves step
two what if I don't own gloves step one
step 0.5 get gloves and a hat and coat
you don't own gloves no not really I
mean like I always have a gloves but
then like I've always lost one or I
can't find one of them and then I go
outside and with one hand stuffed in a
pocket and the other hand with a glove
so I'm just sort of you know we're just
navigating the world that way I found
out when I moved to Montana fifteen
years ago was that having your hands out
in the cold is unpleasant but if you
then touch something with your bare hand
and it is below zero Fahrenheit you have
actually injured yourself so if you
touch something metal when it it like
the the heat from your hand is
instantaneously gone and like you are
actually in trouble now this is a very
important thing to note like it's very
different to have your hand out in the
cold air than to have your hand touching
a cold piece of metal which will happen
if you touch like your door or your
doorknob or a flagpole I don't know what
you're touching that's metal of your
snow shovel like don't touch that
without your leather gloves on and that
that is a very important lesson that I
learned the hard way well Hank I just
want to tell you one thing right now
which is that yesterday it was colder in
Indianapolis than it was on the South
Pole or possibly at the South Pole I'm
not an expert in preposition is also
everyone
you just said in the South Lake Paul
really really good advice yeah but it's
it's the South Pole everything you said
sounds like really good advice the issue
I guess I have with your advice and I
know that this is an advice podcast and
we should get to the advice portion
quickly but like the only question I
have about your advice is like why I
have no I'm I'm not gonna go outside for
longer than like a minute like I'm gonna
take out the trash other than that I'm
gonna hunker down and wait for this to
end
well if you live in a place like
Missoula Montana where the Sun starts to
go down at 4:30 and and that and it
often doesn't come up at all because we
only have like a hundred and twenty days
of sunshine a year it's very important
to your health to go outside even if
outside is very bad for your health so
Hank as you know I've been trying to go
outside more but right now I'm just I'm
I'm just not gonna do it rather than get
a pair of gloves I think I'm just gonna
wait this out let's get to some
questions from our listeners you're
taking the most dangerous possible
course this first question what and what
way am i taking the most dangerous but
easily the most dangerous possible
course would be just take off all of my
clothes and walk outside without wearing
gloves is basically the same as being
nude but i mean i i'd like to see a
randomized control trial on not wearing
gloves when it's zero degrees outside
versus standing outside nude when it's
zero degrees outside I'd love to see I'm
not sure how you'd make a double-blind
randomized control trial because I feel
like the placebo would be pretty hard
I favor be pretty hard for people to
know whether they were nude or I feel
like it'd be pretty hard for people not
to know whether they were nude but I'm
pretty sure science would be with me on
this one but let's let's move on first
question comes from Justin who asks dear
Hank and John our hamsters pistols our
hamster happen to live outside in the
wild where would such a majestical
creature be found this the answer the
sake I do yeah Syria yeah along other
places in in that that part of the world
but yeah that the hamsters that we have
came from a single breeding pair that
was brought to the u.s. from Syria
yeah we're just yeah and there it's
called the Syrian hamster they dig very
deep burrows their burrows can be like
20 or 30 feet deep because it's pretty
it's pretty hot and so they dig 20 or 30
feet down just to get get nice and
comfortable which might be why hamsters
tend to like those very long tunnels
that are just slightly larger than
themselves ya know yeah that's exactly
that's exactly why that's why they are
encouraged you are encouraged as a
hamster owner to get them those tunnels
because they feel at home in them gerbil
let me back okay quick did you just say
that they came from a single breeding
pair from Syria yeah not only did they
come from a single breeding pair from
Syria the breeding pair was a
brother-sister pair whoa
wait so there's an Adam and Eve of like
American hamster yeah yeah yeah a
hundred percent and and they've done
studies to see if this is like
problematic but it turns out that they
are wild genetically distinct and
different from native wild hamsters they
are okay
they seem to be just fine so apparently
maybe they had some good systems for
dealing with inbreeding
already genetically I don't know wait so
if we went down to two humans which I
think that would be bad by the way happy
new year and I I think we all know that
2018 is the year where it's 50/50
whether we go down to two humans if we
went down to two humans what would that
be like a medium-sized problem or a big
problem I'm pretty sure it would be a
big problem but I couldn't tell you I've
not I've only read people saying that
that would be a big problem I have not
read why people have said that would be
a big problem okay yeah I would well
let's just hope that let's just hope
that the half of outcomes in the weird
corner of the multiverse in which we
find ourselves we're more than two
humans survive the year let's hope that
we're in that half it is really weird to
me to think about wild hamsters and
gerbils like they're so like so
intrinsically pet animals to me like
yeah that it's it's but in some places
in the world they're basically just
squirrels right they're basically just
ground squirrels that the version that
they have there
dribbles are actually endangered in
their native Indian native habitat of
Mongolia where they are a prop vest
hmm yeah I would imagine that their crop
pests to be fair and I know that I'm
gonna alienate a lot of our listeners
I'm not crazy about gerbils like I it's
an interesting question like at what
point like if an animal showed up in
your house at what point do you treat it
like a pet like if a puppy showed up at
my house tomorrow I'd be like all right
you can stay but like if a raccoon this
has actually happened recently showed up
in my attic I wouldn't be like oh here's
some food and water and let's make a go
of it together you know so at what point
like I feel like if it was a hamster I
might be able to be like alright you're
my pet now but if it was a gerbil I
might be like I'm gonna need you to do
your best out there outside in
Indianapolis have a negative 20 degree
Indianapolis I I don't understand why a
gerbil and a hamster would be different
in that regard is it because yeah I mean
I I can't explain it myself I think
journals are just a little too big for
me they're small they're smaller than a
hamster maybe I'm not imagining it
you're I am imagining a guinea pig that
I've googled a gerbil they also are not
welcome because they look too much like
mice they do have long tails which makes
them look a little mousy but I had girls
when we first moved to Montana and I
liked them a lot we named them ok the
mongolian names because that's where
they're from oh well that's sweet what
happened to them they died of natural
causes well that is I guess the best way
to go this next question comes from
Ricker
who writes Dear John and Hank my
grandmother died this year that's really
we're going back to our roots Hank all
death all the time and when we were
going through her things not wanting to
be wasteful I took an unopened packet of
sponges they're not special sponges or
anything but my question is should I
treat them differently from normal
sponges it feels odd just to throw out
these mementos of my grandmother when
they get brown and gross but I mean
there
literally just sponges am I being
disrespectful of the dead candy is dandy
but I'll always be quicker Ricker ah
that's good like like there's a person
named Ricker in the world me too right
I mean this is up to you Ricker it's how
you feel about your sponges but I think
that you've made the decision which is
that they're sponges and there are there
are other mementos of your grandmother
that are important to you and that
you're gonna hold on to and that you're
maybe not I get browning that's not in
the ED is not in the question you know
at no point is it established maybe like
it was one of the situations where
everybody was in the house and there
were a lot of grandchildren and all
Ricker got with sponges in which case
you do have to keep the sponges yeah I
don't know though I mean at what point
like that at some point imagine like
over the court I assume Ricker's fairly
young but imagine over the course of
Ricker's life imagine that every time
someone Ricker nose dies Ricker and I
hope you don't feel like this is a
disrespectful Ricker but I'm just trying
to play out the possibilities here
every time someone Ricker nose dies
Ricker goes into the kitchen of the
deceased person immediately goes
underneath the sink grabs the sponges
and like that's just kind of that's
Ricker's thing everybody knows like oh
you know grandpa died my great aunt
sally sally su died like everybody knows
that you know we can split stuff up the
way we want to but Ricker gets the
sponges I mean I have a concern which is
that like if and when you cohabitate
with anyone ever they're gonna open
those sponges unless you keep them in
somewhere very very good and obvious
like unless you get like a shadow box
for your sponges yeah people are not
gonna think to treat your sponge
collection with respect because of how
they what I liked about this question
Hank is that it gets at something weird
about humans which is that we we like
associate artifacts with their history
and this is true of anything by the way
like you know costume jewelry becomes
far more valuable to us when it's our
grandmother's costumes
yes then when it's just you know
something that you can buy at a party
supply store I mean you don't have to
end by this to me John I get I get like
sentimentally attached to a rock if I
kick it more than three times I feel the
exact same way that fourth time you kick
a rock you think to yourself well I
better pick this up and put it in my
rock collection and then you put it in
your rock collection and you looky at
least for me I literally have a rock
collection I look at my rock collection
I'm like I wonder where all these rocks
come from I have no memory of any of
them yeah well and it is important to
note that kind of all value stems from
humans assigning the value to the thing
so that's this doesn't mean that that
value doesn't exist it is just as real
as all other value exactly that's why
I'm saying like you can have a sponge
that is incredibly meaningful and
important to you and so I think the call
is yours Rick or like when you look at
that sponge do you think like this
sponge brings back wonderful memories
and this will be a great story to tell
my grandchildren someday about their
great-great grandmother or do you say
like you know nanny would have wanted me
to use these sponges quickly and
efficiently and thoroughly which is what
like when I think about my own
grandmothers I feel like both of them
would not have wanted us to remember
them via the sponges what do you have of
what do you have from your grandparents
Hank to you do you hold on to anything
I've got a few tools from Papa's tool
shed old yellow things like well this
thing that measures how many rotations
something would have rotated if you
stick it in I don't know what that would
be used for but I think that it's pretty
cool I've got an elephant from from
dad's dad you know I've got some
Christmas ornaments from nanny that kind
of thing yeah I've mostly kept Christmas
ornaments because they do have a big
sentimental value in our home although
in many cases the Christmas ornaments
with the most sentimental value are the
weirdest Christmas ornaments and people
are always like where did you get that
from and I'm like oh well it's a long
sad story and then there
like tell it and I'm like okay but it's
really sad and then at the end they're
like well that was sad and I'm like I
don't know what I taught mmm
next question this next question John it
comes from Maria and we're gonna stick
to the theme when someone is buried at
sea
do they make the coffin heavy so it
sinks to the bottom or do they leave it
to float along the surface I need to
know because I'm thinking that I would
quite like to be buried at sea although
I am scared of the sea and of death Ave
Maria that's a good name specific spine
off yeah I I do not know the answer to
this ache I have to say I am NOT an
expert in burial at sea and it is
something that I have wanted very much
to avoid if at all possible about bury
let's say you're looking for a burial at
land that's that sort of your plan
correct oh yeah I'm looking for whatever
a burial or a cremation at land and then
I would like to have a headstone right
regardless of whether my body is
actually there I like I'm a big fan of
headstones I like visiting the
headstones of our relatives so yeah that
that would be my ideal situation it's
not super important to me because I of
course will not be present right
I find the phrase burial at sea which is
very clearly the phrase a little funny
because burying does seem to indicate
some amount of digging that has not
happened with very human sea but I did
look up some specifics of burial at sea
and you can be buried at sea the the
laws are different from state to state
but in the United States you can be
buried at sea as long as you get to
someplace where it's more than six
hundred feet deep and more than three
miles offshore something like that you
might want to look into the specifics
you're considering this hmm sometimes
you need a funeral director president
present and sometimes you do not but you
do need to be in a metal coffin that
will sink and that is also the case for
the Navy when they are burying people at
sea they do their best to put them in it
in a box that is not gonna float because
that would be probably just a boat at
sea then you would just be in a death
boat
and you'd probably write somewhere
eventually what about the Viking thing
where they just put you on a tiny little
boat and then they burn the boat right I
mean there's a little bit of a mix there
you know you get a little bit of both it
does seem like you don't want a super
tiny boat you need a boat that's gonna
get hot enough so that it's just not I
don't want to get too into specifics
here but you want the pieces to be
mostly unrecognizable if they show back
up somewhere after having been washed
around in the ocean sure okay well I
still want to avoid it right No uh yeah
I I would like to have a tree or
something I don't know I feel it I feel
like I'm getting more interested in as
you have said a place for people to go
to but I'd yeah I I and I like
cemeteries I just don't know if there if
we recreated the idea from scratch which
of course is not how humans do things
and so I don't expect this to happen I
don't know that we would end up with
cemeteries it might be something more
like at this point a little more
friendly and inviting then I feel like a
cemetery can be sometimes I don't know I
think it all depends
I didn't tell you this Hank but this is
an amazing true fact a few days ago
rosianna forwarded an email that came in
to my public facing email address from
the sales team at our local cemetery
here in Indianapolis I don't want to
mess up the reordering I think sure you
want a free order your death spot I yeah
I don't want to mess up the name of the
team that she worked on so I'm just
gonna make sure I read it my name is
redacted and I am an advanced planning
advisor at a cemetery name redacted
advanced planning advisor I mean I guess
there's sort of like two two kinds of
salespeople right
there's the advanced planning
salespeople who try to get out ahead of
the issue by it but like years or
decades and then there's the you know
post yeah planning advisors I don't know
I don't know what their take is so a
rush team
Oh God okay yeah I anyway I was like huh
I guess I am now of an age where it
feels not that weird for somebody to
email me cold and say have you
considered where you would like your
eternal remains to be buried and if not
how about our cemetery John it is home
it is home to more dead vice presidents
than any other location on earth was
that part of the pitch oh no it's just
something I know about that cemetery
Indiana has a really strong history of
producing vice presidents who don't
become president it's like a weirdly
it's not to say that that's going to
happen with Mike Pence
however like Indiana has produced Dan
Quayle right so many and Dan Quayle by
the way is not even dead um so when he
does die I assume he will be buried at
Crown Hill Cemetery and then there will
be yet one more vice president who never
became president buried right there yeah
I respect the time it's gonna redact the
name of the cemetery but then I guess I
decided not to I mean well you did give
us a telling fact if we're gonna talk
about the vice president's people can
look it up if they want to the question
yeah can I just get her to give you a
little list sure of dead vice presidents
that are at Crown Hill Cemetery yes
all right hit me vice presidents Charles
W Fairbanks Thomas a Hendricks and
Thomas are Marshall are all buried at
Crown Hill Wow I would not have been
able to tell you that those were
definitely people oh I mean uh none of
them are even remotely famous vice
presidents Thomas a Hendricks was vice
president for Grover Cleveland Charles W
Fairbanks was vice president for Teddy
Roosevelt for a bit from 1905 to 1909
and I don't the other one I don't even
know well
they've also got a president John at
Crown Hill Cemetery possibly sure the
least like if you were gonna name them
my guess would be that this would be of
the
world naming presidents the last on the
list that no wood would remember old
then Benjamin no way at all Benjamin
anybody know the last name of a
president named Benjamin Harrison
Harrison Benjamin Harrison I believe
he's the only president Bend I believe
you are correct that he is the only
president been preceded and succeeded by
Grover Cleveland that's right he was in
the he was the meat in a Grover
Cleveland sandwich something that we all
should strive to be God man who very few
people have ever been so lucky I was
like I have to say these words now I
don't know what I'm going to say them
Benjamin Harrison is not even one of the
10 worst American pressing he's bad I'm
saying he's forgettable because he's
from Indianapolis which is where it's
just I think I think that Vice Blake
like unsuccessful vice presidents are
often from Indianapolis in the same way
that like you know you want you want to
represent American Indianapolis is where
all the chain restaurants go to try out
their first try because it's basically
just just distilled America down there
that's right do you want to know
something interesting hank when we have
the next president he said hopefully if
there is another President of the United
States that will that will be the moment
when Benjamin Harrison becomes the exact
middle president maybe by yeah by number
maybe that's why so forgettable because
he's just smack in the middle like we
got the history and we got the the
recents but the middle is just like I
don't know what's going on and he was a
one internal piece it said that he was a
one-term president
and very very average and slightly
corrupt but more successful than the
three other people who served in the
executive branch at the US government
who are buried in crown Hill because all
of them never became President Hank
let's move on to another question before
I have to contemplate my mortality any
further is this
I'm gonna be not about death this
question is not about death Hank okay it
is about the death of one's career it
comes from Molly and the question is
Dear John and Hank I just started my new
graphic design job last month and as
part of the graphics team it's my job to
create the retirement PowerPoint for a
longtime employee I don't know anything
about this guy or how to make a
personable retirement PowerPoint
especially since this is my first job
I barely know how to start much less
retired vice requested at your earliest
convenience never ordinary always a Dom
moly anomaly I get it
I even a thing that is a job everything
about this situation is a disaster first
off how unpopular must this longtime
employee be that everyone was like oh
god who's gonna make the PowerPoint for
Rick oh I know we can make Molly do it
she's brand new instead of being like oh
I'd love to do it
Rick's an old friend of mine it's like
the ultimate insult yeah like I mean
he's like hey you go mommy you gotta you
gotta ask around I guess you got to get
people to send you some pictures of Rick
maybe find Rick's Facebook or at least
his LinkedIn and be like okay how long's
Rick been with the company what if his
job titles Idol you got it what are you
supposed to do you can't give this job
to a person it's like a nice anniversary
could you make us like a really
heartfelt a video that be great Allah
sends you 50 please put a PowerPoint
together I here's what I would do in
this situation cuz Molly I don't think
this is a great work environment I'm
gonna be honest with you I think you
need to move on from this job and I
think the best way to say goodbye to
this job is via a really hilarious
retirement powerpoint for Rick so I
think the background music has to be
wind beneath my wings um did you ever
know that you're my hero and I think it
all just has to be fading in and out of
the same picture of Rick that's just his
work ID picture just fade in and it's
Rick's idea Fincher and then you do that
slow fade out and then it's like what's
the next slide gonna be
Oh Oh No it's Rick's ID fixture again
and it's the hell did you ever know that
you're my hero and then the last frame
the last frame because I got a great
idea fades out and it's a bald eagle
with a Rick's idea superimposed over the
head just that's it and it's just maybe
underneath that underneath that in
script it says like Rick 1964 to 2018
yeah like he died exactly like he died
like he died and he left behind this
photo this is a work ID with a bald
eagle
it's beautiful Molly and you will never
have to make another retirement
PowerPoint as long as you are a person
working at this company I mean I just
have to say I appreciate Rick's
long-term dedication to the company and
I if you can find a way to do that do it
but I don't know how to do it without
like being like Rick I have to get to
know your real quick tell me about your
mom tell me about your family like how
did you get this job where did you start
my man what did you want to be tell me
about that summer when you were a
commercial fisherman in Alaska yeah yeah
another thing you might do is like ask
Rick about all the things that he wanted
to do other than the career he ended up
having and then like Photoshop Rick into
those jobs so that Rick can imagine like
what it would have been like if he'd
made it to Major League Baseball or
whatever because I find that that's
always something something you want to
make people feel upon their retirement
this is such a terrible job to have been
given it is so highly inappropriate on
every level and I hope by the way Hank
PS I hope that when I retire from
complexly that there is no frickin
PowerPoint at my retirement party also
that there is no retirement party at my
retirement party can everyone just
please give me five dollars thank you
very much that's a wonderful party
John or make a donation to a charity in
my name without having me to be
physically press
and for anything yeah John yes can we
answer the question that we got the most
this episode which is what do I do with
the present that I was given that I did
not want why do we still do presents oh
I mean it is a disaster from a
macroeconomic standpoint like why why do
we try to put people on when they can
just tell us like like we had Liz who
was it who got the quesadilla maker yeah
somebody terrible present I don't want
to criticize Liz's mom for getting her a
quesadilla maker but like and I also
don't want to criticize other people who
maybe got quesadilla makers or gave them
for Chris what a ludicrous Christmas
present of all the things that can be
made without a specific appliance for
the job quesadillas have to be very near
the top of the list the other thing is
that like this first of all it's not Liz
it's nutmeg I don't know why I said it
is it's like the thing that nutmeg liked
doing is making quesadillas and so
somebody was like Liz likes thoughtless
somebody was like nutmeg well as making
quesadillas so let's get nut make a
quesadilla maker what no I I liked
making quesadillas I don't need to have
that step taken out I'm good at it the
way that I'm good at it and I like it
the way that I'm doing it there's what
do you thinks John and it's so hard to
come up with good presents for people
the McIlroy's were talking on their last
episode about having a special golden
acorn that you give to someone instead
of giving them a present to be like here
I don't know I don't know it's just I
don't know I got nothing
here's a golden acorn and that's that's
the present now and you can give that
golden acorn to somebody else and just
pass him around and be like I thought
about you which is all we really are
trying to say right I got actually
though I have to say I got really good
presents from you and Katherine and I
did think to myself like Hank and
Katherine really thought about what I
would want this year and the
particularity and specificity of those
presents was really Pleasant for me I
got a indy500 program from 1974 which
was really cool it was really cool to
read through that and it's just like
anybody who knows me knows how much I
like the
500 and then I got I can't remember what
else but it was something else you gave
me a signed like a signed first edition
of caleb west master diver which is okay
west master diver two class new year
thing to have found and i don't even
know how you found it and it's amazing
to me that it even existed and it isn't
now a prized possession luckily I have
an unsigned unfurnished copy that I can
actually read yeah nobody knows what
caleb west master diver is Hank
oh I think we talked about it what I
don't know where we've talked about it
but Caleb west master diver was the most
popular book of like 1896 in America
like the top book in the world and of
course America and of course everyone
has now forgotten what it is but it's a
book about a guy building a lighthouse
in England and it's was named
astonishingly is not caleb west no yeah
no Caleb West is the diver yeah hey that
this guy employs he's basically like a
general contractor and he works with a
bunch of like very like hard-working
American men on building a lighthouse
and they all have very good skills and
they never complain about anything
except like occasionally the wind right
it's a very it's a story of American
like industrialization in an age where
like the idea of building a lighthouse
was so incredibly exciting that you
could sell two million books just
writing a book about it where nothing
else happens yeah I mean there's like a
love interest kinda and so on but yes
most of there's a lighthouse being built
and the writer Francis Hopkinson Smith
actually built lighthouses and you can
see one of them race rock lighthouse is
probably his best his best lighthouse
it's very cool yeah what a shrine
actually we'll put up we'll put race
Rock lighthouse on the patreon he also
built the the base of the Statue of
Liberty before becoming the best-selling
novelist of the 1890s in the United
States fascinating character Francis
Hopkinson Smith he lived he lived a
thousand lives he was one of those
people who lived a bunch of different
lives he was also one of the most famous
visual artists of his time and now his
paintings are in the permanent
collection of many of America's leading
museums and yet his paintings in in
private sales sell for only a few
hundred
because he is so completely forgotten
anyway I don't know how we got on that
tough almost it's almost as if we've
been learning an awful lot about Francis
Hopkinson Smith for a potential project
that we are making about it we're
thinking about it I still don't think
we've quite pulled the trigger yet but
we're thinking about it anyway Hank I
want to get to this question really
quickly if you don't mind it's from pre
who writes Dear John and Hank I moved
into my new apartment in Sydney about
three months ago well that was your
first mistake pre everybody knows that
if you live in Australia or New Zealand
you should live in New Zealand because
it has no natural predators the thing
that I'm always concerned about is
natural predators that's my main concern
not like commute time or weather but
whether or not something might bite me
that is exactly my main concern anyway
the apartments really cute and quirky
and I have a lovely housemate but every
so often I hear some sort of animal on
my roof through the bathroom vents and
girls would not be a problem so I am
concerned okay it sounds like a possum
but it could also be a giant rat I mean
why do you think that those are mutually
exclusive
a possum is a giant rat anyway this one
time I kept some cooked bacon in my
bathroom to lure it to my vents to take
a look at what it was but at last my
experiment was unsuccessful
it sounds really cute and I want to see
it but I cannot any suggestion what kind
of person here's a bulldog yet hold on
Jon yeah possums are different in
Australia are they really and they're
cuter wait let me Google Australian
opossum I mean they're not cute Oh God
Oh God disaster but it was better than
an American opossum which is just like
no no hardly babies Google baby
australian possum baby australian possum
and they're like oh yes please give me
two no no no this all this makes me love
new zealand ever more is there a looming
cold ah maybe Google New Zealand possum
I bet there isn't one there is no dangit
there is there is one it's the common
brush tail possum
the same possum yeah and possum it's
swam from Australia to New Zealand
that's n't know it was introduced by
Europeans said take European settlers
that's right ruining everything they're
all over the place they used to be
nowhere but in the last thirty years
they've gotten everywhere mmm of course
of course well pre what I would do in
this situation is just move I do like
your openness to the to the possibility
here that it is something that you might
quite like to see I know that you think
that the animal crawling around in your
vents sounds really cute and does not
really usually how I respond to the
sound of an unknown intruder in my home
but I do like you I do like that
perspective I like that you think that
you think you hear something adorable
and that you don't think man I wonder if
there I wonder if that is a boa
constrictor there was at our old office
a man living between the floors yeah I
remember that there was a it was like a
13 and a half 1/2 floor issue like in
being John Malkovich my feeling about
this pre is that if you're the kind of
person who's not totally freaked out in
this situation and you think it's great
and you're putting bacon there for this
guest like you are of a kind you're a
kind of like hardcore and open to the
world that I will never be and so I
can't give you advice on this topic
because you're so far outside the realm
of anything that I can understand which
reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by really amazing
Australians amazing Australians unafraid
of possums this podcast is also brought
to you by Ricker's dead person sponge
collection it's just a bunch of dead
people sponges and this pod guys also
brought to you by hamsters hamsters they
just they just want to be 20 feet under
the ground and also this podcast is
brought to you by John's sad Christmas
tree ornaments ah you didn't probably
didn't want to ask for that story did
you
no no also today's podcast has actually
brought to you by our friends at
Squarespace Hank I recently knew
to update my website you know I have a
website John Green books calm did you
know that I have another job I'm not a
professional podcaster I'm aware of
multiple of your jobs John I've got your
career pretty closely I appreciate that
so I had to update John Green books calm
to reflect the fact that my new book
Turtles all the way down was published
and to put in some of the reviews some
of the things that people said about it
and it was so incredibly easy if you've
been making websites as I have since the
early 1990s
Squarespace just feels like a miracle
like it's so easy it and I'm not just
saying that because they're sponsoring
the podcast it's like you can have a
professional-looking website
inexpensively and it's not hard yeah
yeah and and and your website is good
and it has lots of information and on
the front page the second thing on it is
the pod so thanks for shout now yeah I
know and you can you can integrate the
different lots of different online
platforms including of course SoundCloud
which means that you can just slap a
SoundCloud embed into the site and it
looks nice and Squarespace knows what
it's doing with those I also use
Squarespace for my personal website and
really enjoyed creating that website and
and it was you know it was easy but it
also looks really good in it
I I had been wanting to do that for a
long time to get myself an updated just
place where you go and like you know
just take a brochure place and it's a
there's a lot of different templates and
they are all very usable and but also
very customizable
and there are and it also lets you
really easily get a domain if you don't
have one but if you do have a domain
it's pretty easy to plug into your
existing domain name which is what I did
and lets you showcase your work lets you
blog if you want a blog you can even
sell products through Squarespace it has
an e-commerce option as well yeah you
can do a bunch of stuff with your
Squarespace site it's good it's easy
it's why everybody's always talking
about Squarespace it's true check out
Squarespace comm slash dear John you can
also use squarespace.com slash dear Hank
but that webs that that is not as
effective so what do you
John if you go to squarespace.com slash
dear you get 10% off but if you go to
squarespace.com slash Dear John you'll
really get 10% off your first order glad
we got that fettle squarespace.com slash
Dear John thanks again to Squarespace
for sponsoring today's show Hank let's
answer one more question before we get
to the all-important news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon all right John this
question comes from Chris ax who asks
dear Hank and John I'm 22 years old
and I've recently taken a job where my
primary responsibility is to plan a
series of four hour-long events four
times a year
these events are aimed at nurturing the
startup ecosystem in my country the
Philippines and I'm privileged to have
the support of more prominent people in
the tech and startup community but they
are not required to help me and they
essentially get nothing out of helping
me I also have no supervisor and no one
I'm directly reporting to no one is
telling me what to do or what to aim for
I feel like I and I want to enjoy my job
because it sounds like so much fun to be
able to self supervise but I have no key
performance indicators it's great that
you're using the lingo to know if I'm
doing well or if I'm behind I fear that
I may be too young to be left
unsupervised any dubious advice on my
situation would be incredibly
appreciated remembering to be awesome
Chrissa this is a great question and I
appreciate it and I also appreciate
somebody dumping this much
responsibility on you and saying figure
it out it's not great management but
sometimes sometimes that is the path
that that's sort of like that a bit of a
trial by fire to be like you're gonna
learn a lot really quickly and it may
not produce the best result and it may
not be the most pleasant thing but you
are gonna learn a lot yeah yeah no I
mean I think you've got a for lack of a
better term lean in to that lack of
supervision and just understand that
you're not going to be perfect at this
to start I always try to tell myself
whenever I'm doing something new that I
never have the expectation that like my
children are going to be amazing at
something the first time they try it
like I'm never like Oh Alice you're
about to get on ice skates you will be
at the Olympics next month right like I
put Alice on ice skates and she falls
down a bunch
then she starts to fall down less and
then she starts to get going and you
know pretty soon she can skate forwards
and I think you have to have that same
set of expectations and if the people
you work with are giving you this kind
of opportunity like you've got to treat
it as a learning experience rather than
being like oh God
all the things that I do wrong are gonna
be you know they're it's gonna end my
career or whatever it's hard to do that
but I find like it sounds silly but
talking to myself the way I would talk
to my children or someone else that I
care about and love is helpful yeah I
think also putting things into like
bite-size chunks like trying to make a
list of things that you actually want to
get done and if you're having some
pushback from the people that you kind
of need to be supporting you so you'd
like have-have you know people in the
tech and startup community that you're
gonna be want to be featuring and you
want them to be having useful and
interesting conversations it's almost
like I think about events a lot so I
probably have a lot of specific advice
for this specific question but you're
gonna want to give those people
opportunities to feel really cool and
important and it might - you seem like
of course they feel that way but I bet
you that often times they don't and they
want those opportunities to have - to
have to be meaningful in their in their
world and to be put on something of a
pedestal and to have opportunities to
say this stuff that they have learned
and and to inspire people I think that
if you can find the stuff that motivates
people to actually get up on stage and
lend you a little bit of their expertise
that's really what what is it's sort of
the key to unlocking this and that might
mean learning a lot about them
individually it also might be learning
about sort of how people talk about and
get excited about entrepreneurialism
which probably means listening to lots
of entrepreneurial podcasts and reading
up on whatever all those things are and
sort of like getting a little bit
obsessed with it and driving you're
driving your brain into into that world
and and that's a lot to ask and it's a
lot of new information to synthesize all
at once
so I I appreciate you taking on a hard
thing and I know I have both been in the
situation and put people in the
situation where you feel too young to be
left unsupervised and it can be a really
great experience and it can be really
hard one though so thanks for your
question all right Hank let's move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon if
you don't mind I'll go first all right
okay Hank
so the Christmas period is very busy the
Christmas and New Year period very busy
for English soccer teams there is no
holiday break in the span of eight days
Wimbledon played four League one games
which is a lot and from those four games
they emerged with seven points which is
great that is really not half bad they
beat Southend United to nil with goals
from actually stunningly non-striker's
two of our first non striker goals of
the season from Liam Trotter and Tom
Soares that to know victory by the way
matches AFC Wimbledon's biggest win of
the year
so yeah that may got a 2-2 draw at
Gillingham fighting back it must be said
fighting back they were down they were
down in that game twice and fought back
for a 2-2 draw goals from Harry Forester
and a penalty from the Montserrat Egan
Messi Lyle Taylor they and then and then
before that they lost to Portsmouth and
then before that they beat Bradford City
2-1 which is probably the best win of
the year so far for Wimbledon Bradford
City are up there at the top of the
table while Taylor scored a 70th minute
goal to put the Dons up to one in that
game and held on for the win I mean
unfortunately despite this relatively
good run of form seven points from four
games AFC Wimbledon are currently still
in the league one relegation zone
they're in 21st place 27 points after 25
games in order to stay up Wimbledon are
probably gonna need like 50 150 maybe 52
points so we've got
21 games left to play and from those 21
games we need 24 or 25 points so 8 wins
from 20 games it's possible it's gonna
be yeah it's stressful Hank there's no
getting around it it's a very stressful
situation even with 21 games to go but
hopefully this good run of form will
continue and we'll be okay well I mean
it seems like things are going I mean
that's good right you're yeah yeah if we
score if we get seven points from every
four games that we play for the rest of
the season we'll stay up comfortably
yeah yeah yeah but you won't it won't be
more than that you won't be like in the
in the mid middle or anything you know
the one of the weird things about this
season in Ligue 1 is that AFC Wimbledon
despite being currently in the
relegation zone are only 6 points away
from being in 11th right but I mean I
frankly to be completely honest with you
do I care if we finished 19th or 11th I
do not it should also be noted that the
franchise currently applying its trade
in Milton Keynes is in 19th and and
Wimbledon are only two points off of of
Milton Keynes which is you would turn of
events and that is our next league game
we'll be playing them away but before
then and actually after this but this
game will have already happened by the
time the podcast is uploaded this
weekend is our big money ball game
against toss Hotspur you haven't gotten
your money yet I didn't realize I
thought that it already happened oh no
it's coming January 6th AFC Wimbledon
play Tottenham at Wembley Stadium AFC
Wimbledon of course currently undefeated
at Wembley never been beaten at Wembley
and that made a change on Saturday but
currently never been beaten at Wembley
and I am taking a lot of hope it taught
him have played a ton of football in the
last week and a half and they haven't
looked
good they look tired I think they're
gonna rest some of their stars and I
feel a miracle coming all right John
well I'll be watching sports with John
on Twitter to see what happens and thank
you to my phone for always keeping me
updated now on my news page with the
scores because these days I always know
I always know how things are going
John Mars yes yes so a some researchers
just wrote a paper and it's a sort of a
white paper it's kind of thing in the
journal Nature Geoscience which is a
really big scientific journal the the
different way like the way that we
imagine how we're life would be and how
to find evidence of life is very
different if you were if you really want
to think about how life might work on
Mars mm-hmm like photosynthesis of
course is what drives the vast majority
of life on Earth you either are you
either are getting energy from the Sun
or you're getting energy from things
that got into you from the Sun and
you're getting energy from things that
got an energy from things that are that
got energy from the Sun like it's just
that's how the Cascade works and there's
very there is some what they call
chemosynthesis where where you take
chemicals that have energy in them and
you go straight from the chemistry into
the life and that happens that like
deep-sea vents and stuff but almost all
of its photosynthesis and so we're sort
of used to photosynthesis like life and
that's that's life that needs to be on
the surface in order to get access to
the Sun all right on Mars one there it
seems that there are a number of
potential chemosynthesis candidates
there's a lot of hydrogen there's a lot
of maybe hydrogen sulfide and that stuff
can be synthesized by bacteria into
useful energy that they can then use to
like continue to be alive so that those
things seem to exist and also the
surface of Mars is not a great place
there's no atmosphere there hasn't been
an atmosphere for a long time there's no
magnetic field so it's constantly being
bombarded by a high-energy solar
particle
and so that can really mess up any life
forms strategies for self replication
and such so you know that the the thing
that these writers are these researchers
are saying and Nature Geoscience is like
probably if we're gonna look for like
really look for life on Mars and this is
a pressing question because Mars gonna
be sending the 2020 Rover fairly soon
and that's sort of one of the first
missions that has the express purpose of
we're gonna actually try and look for
life on Mars rather than more geology
based missions like what curiosity's
been doing then this matters a lot and
if it's just gonna be like collecting
rocks from the surface and doing science
on those rocks and maybe even collecting
them for a later return to earth and a
sample return mission then like if
you're just picking from the surface
you're probably not gonna find a lot
because it's a pretty harsh place and so
they're encouraging maybe like looking
at can we be looking like and collecting
samples and also analyzing samples from
what are called mineralized fracture
zones and I'm gonna quote now these
would be places where there was fluid
flow in the crust and where you get
mixing between different fluids from
different sources that have potentially
different concentration concentrations
of important elements as well as
dissolved hydrogen which is a potential
source of energy for microbes so like
cracks in the crust where water may have
been coming from above but also
groundwater it would be mixing and
bringing energy in the form of these
chemo synthesis candidates to to
potential life that would be looking to
to continue surviving using using
chemical energy so that's uh that's what
they're looking at and and I don't know
that this is like it does seem to be
like if we're gonna be finding life on
Mars that there's also some heat left it
would appear inside of Mars so that heat
like just sort of the way that you know
earth obviously has a lot of heat on the
inside of it that heat is less there on
Mars because it's a small
planet and it has it's a lot easier to
cool off if you're a smaller thing but
it seems like there's still some
geothermal heat which could be melting
water which could be meaning lots of
good chemical soups down there for
interesting things to happen but but
what what we are learning is if we don't
find life on Mars it's not gonna mean
that there is no life on Mars there's
going to be a lot of looking for a long
long time mmm-hmm that's really
interesting yeah I mean it is very
strange to think about and this is
something I've been thinking about in
the context of your book Hank it is very
strange to think about what
first-contact looks like outside of the
traditional ways that we've thought
about it or what you know what
interacting with alien life looks like
when you know we haven't even it's it's
just so mind-boggling to think like well
what would life look like if it weren't
dependent upon photosynthesis and we
know what would life look like if it
didn't have DNA or RNA just
mind-boggling really understand a
hundred percent of how it works
with our version of life right we
certainly can can you know ground up or
grind up a rock and see if there was any
DNA in there and we can be like well
there must have been something alive on
that rock but if it's not based on DNA
you've grown up that rock and you're
like well I don't know what I'm looking
for like like well they're complex
complex molecules
what does self-replication look like if
it's not based on the same
self-replication systems we have and
also when you start to talk about like
like it gets much more complicated when
you you get out of just you know sort of
try not to be too jargony here you get
out of just self-replicating molecules
and in self-replicating systems into
like how do things transfer information
and how do you think how do like you
know how do we communicate that would be
a very weird thing which yeah yeah much
much much more
weird and obviously such great places
for science fiction to go and I've
always loved those kinds of books yeah
no I think it's really fascinating well
aside from that Hank what did we learn
today oh gosh John we learned that you
are a prime candidate for for the
advanced planning advisory at your
nearby cemetery interesting terrible
news mr. business we learned that I have
a question is it possible that this is
like can't you be like but I'm like a
kind of a big deal
who wouldn't you just like pay me to be
in your cemetery it's basically like
having another vice president's like
your last brand deal oh my god it's the
last brand deal you'll ever make
I like it because it's dark and weird
but that'd be a funny email to send back
to be like I have a proposal for you
how's about instead of paying for a plot
in your cemetery you pay me for a plot
in your cemetery I mean you're welcome
I feel so good for all the people who
made it through the Mars and AFC will
move the news so that they got that
thanks it already all right
aside from that we learned that a sponge
is only a sponge unless it's more than a
sponge and we also learned that dang it
I don't need a quesadilla maker
I like making quesadillas I am the
quesadilla maker mom it's so true Hank
thank you for parting with me thanks to
everybody for listening we'll be back
next week in the meantime we want to let
you know about the people who make this
podcast this podcast is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and shared and
Gibson it's edited by nicholas jenkins
our head of community and communications
is Victoria bon giorno she's helping out
with all that patreon stuff thank you so
much to all of our supporters on patreon
you can support us for a dollar and you
can choose whether you prefer Mars news
or AFC Wimbledon news or really quite
frankly neither thank you or for $5.00
you can get our upcoming podcast or our
patron only podcast which we are about
to record this week in Ryan's this
podcast is also
the theme music the theme music that you
are hearing right now and at the
beginning of the podcast are by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]